so let's talk about a great word
diegetic saying something is diegetic is
functionally synonymous with the in
world explanation the word refers to the
diagnosis of a story which is the
narrative construct that everything
takes place in it's like a bubble
universe conceptually some whole place
with its own rules in reality just
elsewhere so when something is diegetic
it happens in world when something is
non-diegetic it doesn't happen the
textbook example of the line between
diegetic and non-diegetic elements is
the soundtrack the music comes in the
audience hears it but it doesn't come
from anywhere in the story world it
doesn't exist in the same space as the
characters however it's not uncommon for
storytellers to call attention to this
convention by playing with the boundary
between the two perhaps by redefining
something that appears to be
non-diegetic as a diegetic element like
i inserted some soundtrack music over
this segment to illustrate the point and
I'm now going to reveal my ipod in order
to suggest that the music was audible to
me in this space the whole time
often this or any other case where the
illusory mechanisms of storytelling are
acknowledged or revealed is called
breaking the fourth wall while the
fourth wall is a similar construct to
the diocese it refers explicitly to the
barrier of perception and address
between the audience and the diagnosis
taking its name from stage traditions
sets on a stage are in the proscenium
tradition built with three walls with an
imaginary fourth wall represented
physically by the curtain dividing the
audience from the actors in film the
construct of the screen functions as a
similar divide a physical barrier that
is through the contrivance of fiction
transparent to the audience in this
regard the two concepts are
complementary the diagnosis is the world
the characters inhabit and the fourth
wall is the idea that separates us from
that world in this conceptualization
non-diegetic elements happen at the
fourth wall an easy way to think of it
would be like a one-way pane of glass
and non-diegetic elements like text are
painted right on to the outside surface
this right here doesn't exist in my
space I am in fact waving my hands at
nothing so on-screen text and
non-diegetic
nouns are the easiest non-diegetic
elements to demonstrate but can we find
something a little more complicated like
what about editing yes editing the act
of cutting from one shot to another
there is no physical phenomenon that
this replicates it's not a thing that
exists in the world of the characters
yet it alters our perception of their
space by changing our point of view
compressing time creating a symmetry and
the knowledge of the audience versus the
knowledge of the characters and so on
when one shot ends and another begins
we're in space does that exist
well no where it's an illusion of
storytelling that exists between the
diagnosis and the audience at the 4th
wall now just in case this wasn't
confusing enough it's worth reminding
you that the digest doesn't exist at all
nothing is literally diegetic because
the world of the film isn't real it is
created in your mind by the illusion of
watching it and the agreement you make
with yourself to buy into the things you
see and extrapolate them out into a
persistent mental construct in fact this
clip at the end was recorded first so
let's talk about a great word diegetic